I still can't get over the fact that you
got rejected by American Idol I cannot
believe I mean I watch you sing I mean
who was it was it that the Simon Cowell
I can't remember the years like Simon
and Randy and Paul Abdul I can't even
slag them off because I didn't even get
past the like first open call audition
with how is that possible you sing
beautiful I mean what did you just have
a bad day no I killed it right what what
and your look and the whole thing you
you it seems to me it would have been
like a natural I had to have been
probably 16 or 17 when I went to the
Cowboy stadium in Dallas and did the big
cattle call 20,000 people you only get
10 seconds in your lineup of five to
sing for this tent of like you know
20-year-old producers that you know
their Uncle probably knew someone that
worked at the network I don't know who
knows yeah but I sang um Shaka Kan sweet
thing which is still my karaoke song um
but I nailed it I I did not have a bad
day um I did after that but right did
you did your confidence get rocked at as
a 16-year-old oh if I don't get on this
that's it I'm never going to be a singer
or you didn't care you just kept going
and plowing through I mean it it it
sucked it it hurt for sure just in the
moment you're a teenager and also like
Kelly Clarkson came from my neck of the
woods and won the first ever season so
that was just so inspiring to me as a
Texan but but honestly it wasn't just
American Idol it was the voice it was
America's Got Talent
um right um it was all of them said no W
I am just freaked out by that I'm so
lucky that they did say no because I was
not ready to be in the Limelight or have
any sort of public facing anything the
music was not there my voice was still
maturing even though it was good at the
time I just hadn't found it yet and I
would have been a [__] nightmare like
Teenage signed artist like that sound I
would not have handled it like some of
my peers that have been doing this the
same amount of
time